ein amerikanisches forschungsteam hat
eine wirklich unglaubliche künstliche
intelligenz entwickelt sie kam
tatsächlich den wahrscheinlichsten
todeszeitpunkt eines patienten oder
einer patientin voraussagen und sie
funktioniert wirklich ob
glücklicherweise oder bedauerlicherweise
naja jetzt gibt's für sein pilotprojekt
sie wird in einem krankenhaus getestet
wie die ki genau funktioniert und warum
sie damit das sterben sogar so angenehm
wie möglich macht jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
um no angenehmes sterben durch eine
künstliche intelligenz ki die meinen tod
voraus sagt höra also von anfang an wir
haben ja hier schon öfter über die
planning modelle berichtet eine form der
künstlichen intelligenz die in der lage
ist
riesige datenmengen zu analysieren und
daraus eigenständig zu lernen bei dieser
konkreten ki datenanalyse technik haben
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler neuronaler netzwerke
darauf hin trainiert den
wahrscheinlichsten todeszeitpunkt einer
patientin oder eines patienten
vorauszusagen und konkret die frage zu
beantworten ob eine patientin oder ein
patient innerhalb der nächsten drei bis
zwölf monate sterben wird die prognose
erfolgt innerhalb von 24 stunden nach
der einweisung in ein krankenhaus das
training der ki basierte auf
hunderttausenden patientendaten konkret
wurden die algorithmen mit daten aus 19
jahren und insgesamt mit mehr als 200
21.000 patientenakten gefüttert an der
entwicklung der künstlichen intelligenz
beteiligt waren übrigens
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus dem medizinischen bereich und der
informatik mit hilfe des programms
python eignete sich die ki also
eigenständig an innerhalb von 24 stunden
nach aufnahme einen wahrscheinlichsten
todeszeitpunkt zu prognostizieren und
das anhand der patientendaten und das
ergebnis der ki war wirklich ziemlich
krass in neun von zehn fällen hatte sie
den todeszeitpunkt innerhalb der
vorgegebenen zeitspanne richtig
vorhergesagt und auch in gegensätzlichen
verlag.de oft richtig in 95 prozent der
fälle bei denen die ki vorausgesagt
hatte dass die sterbewahrscheinlichkeit
eher gering war lebten diese tatsächlich
noch länger als ein jahr weiter aber
wofür das ganze
vielleicht macht es ja sinn wenn ihr die
wahl hätte tvo und wie würdet ihr dann
die letzten stunden ihres lebens
verbringen wollen die antwort hängt
sicherlich davon ab unter welchen
umständen das möglich ist ob gesund oder
eben krank für den großteil der menschen
die unheilbar krank sind steht
jedenfalls fest dass sie nicht im
krankenhaus darauf warten wollen dass
sie sterben in den usa beispielsweise
gibt es studien nach denen 80 prozent
der menschen ihre letzte lebenszeit zu
hause
wollen in ihrem gewohnten umfeld und mit
den menschen um sich die ihnen wichtig
sind
das schlimme an der realität aber ist
dass sich 60 prozent der todesfälle
solcher patienten auf der
intensivstation eines krankenhauses
zeiten also genau das was sich todkranke
menschen eben nicht wünschen der grund
dafür liegt den studien zufolge meistens
an einer fehleinschätzung der ärztinnen
und ärzte die behandeln und die die
patienten nicht rechtzeitig in die
palliative versorgung also die
versorgung vor dem tod übergeben und
genau dieses problem ist das
forschungsteam der stanford university
angegangen und hat dafür die künstliche
intelligenz entwickelt diese kann jetzt
ermöglichen das todkranke patienten die
möglichkeit bekommen ihre letzten tage
zu hause verbringen zu können und zudem
palliativ versorgt zu werden diesen
bereich der medizin geht es ja nicht
darum die todkranken patienten so lange
wie möglich am leben zu halten sondern
ihnen stattdessen dem tod so angenehm
wie möglich zu machen für die studie von
großer bedeutung waren vor allem
todkranke menschen die drei bis zwölf
monate nach ihrer aufnahme verstorben
denn sie sind die besten kandidatinnen
und kandidaten für die palliativmedizin
das forschungsteam suchte aus denjenigen
ergebnisse der ki bei denen sie sich am
sichersten waren zufällig 50
patientinnen und patienten aus ihre
daten wurden dann von spezialisten aus
den palliativen bereich bewertet und
zwar dahingehend ob diese tatsächlich
für die palliative versorgung in frage
gekommen wären und die ergebnisse waren
eben wie beschrieben absolut positiv die
künstliche intelligenz wird deswegen
jetzt auch als pilotprojekt am
uniklinikum in stanford eingesetzt und
auch dort soll sie patientinnen und
patienten identifizieren für die eine
palliative versorgung also eben die vor
dem tod angesagt wäre eine wirklich gute
sache
die zukünftig tatsächlich die
gesundheitsvorsorge in großem stil
verbessern könnte doch dafür musik
weiter lernen denn bislang passiert ihr
wissen nur auf den patientendaten aus
zwei krankenhäusern doch auch schon
diese kann mit diesen wenigen daten
schafft es dass die lebensqualität und
das wohlbefinden von todkranken menschen
deutlich verbessert hat bislang stehen
in vielen fällen tatsächlich weitere
medizinische behandlungen auf dem
programm die von den patientinnen
passiert
selbst aber eher als belastend empfunden
werden und auch überhaupt keinen sinn
machen wenn ihr als erstes neues zum
thema karin zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei
whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video garantiert
ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion
von kriegs- und mitmachen und themen
vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos
stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit glocke vergessen und hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
krieg gegen künstliche intelligenz
hacker planen widerstand ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran